rewrite the expression four times than
in parentheses we have eight plus three
using the distributive law of
multiplication over addition then
simplify the expression so let's just
try to solve this or evaluate this
expression and then we'll talk a little
bit about the distributive law of
multiplication over addition usually
just called the distributive law so we
have 4 times 8 4 times 8 plus 8 plus 3 8
plus 3 now there's two ways to do it
normally when you have parentheses your
inclination is well let me just evaluate
what's in the parentheses first and then
worry about what's outside of the
parentheses and we can do that fairly
easily here we can evaluate what 8 plus
3 is 8 plus 3 is 11 so if we do that let
me do that in this direction so if we do
that we get 4 times we get 4 times and
in parentheses we have an 1183 is 11 and
then this is going to be equal to well 4
times 11 is just 44 so you can evaluate
it that way but they want us to use the
distributive law of multiplication we
did not use the distributive law just
now we just evaluated the expression
maybe use the parentheses first then
multiplied by 4 and the distributive law
we multiply by 4 first and it's called
the distributive law because you
distribute the 4 and we're going to
think about what that means so in the
distributive law what this will become
it'll become 4 times 8 plus 4 times 3
and we're going to think about why that
is in a second so this is going to be
equal to 4 times 8 4 times 8 plus 4
times 4 times 3 4 times 3 a lot of
people's first instinct is just to
multiply the 4 times the 8 but know you
have to distribute the 4 you have to
multiply it times times the 8 and times
the 3 this is right here this is the
distributive property in action right
here distributive property in action and
then when you evaluate I'm going to show
you in kind of a visual way why this
word
but then when you evaluate it four times
eight this in a different color 4 times
8 is 32 and then so we have 32 plus 4
times 3 4 times 3 is 12 and 32 plus 12
is equal to 44 that is also equal to 44
so you can get it either way but when
they want us to use the distributive law
you would multiply it you distribute the
4 first now let's think about why that
happens let's let's visualize just what
8 plus 3 is so let me draw 8 of
something so 1 2 3 4 5 6 let me draw it
this well 6 7 8 right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and then we're going to add to that
we're going to add to that 3 of
something of them maybe the same thing
1 2 3 so you could imagine this is what
we have inside of the parentheses we
have 8 circles plus 3 circles now when
we're multiplying this whole thing this
whole thing times 4 what does that mean
well that means we're just going to add
this to itself 4 times so let me do that
with the copy and paste copy and paste
let me copy and then let me paste there
you go that's 2 that's 1 2 3 and then we
have 4 and we're going to add them all
together so this is literally what 4
times right we have it let me go back to
the drawing tool we have it 1 2 3 4
times this expression which is 8 plus 3
now what is this thing over here what is
this thing over here what is this thing
over here if you were to count all of
this stuff you would get 44 but what is
this thing over here
well that's 8 add it to itself 4 times
you could imagine you're adding all of
these so what's 8 add it to itself 4
times that is 4 times 8 so this is 4
times 8 and what is this over here in
the orange we have 1 2 3 4 times well
each time
we have three so it's got four times
this right here this right here is four
times three so you see why the
distributive property works if you do
four times eight plus three you have to
multiply what when you I guess you could
imagine duplicate the thing four times
both the eight and the three is getting
duplicated four times or it's being
added to itself four times and that's
why we distribute the four